hello everyone welcome back to a brand
new video we're back on for honor again
as you can tell by the video today it is
the year four season three resistance
launch and we're going to be talking
about the battle pass tiers today
i haven't looked at the battle pass at
all of course we did cover some of the
stuff that's going to be in the battle
pass but of course we don't know what
tiers they're going to be in and
they're obviously not going to show us
the later tiers so that's more of us to
figure out and that's what we're going
to figure out today as i have no clue
what's going to be in this battle pass
so let's get started with today's video
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
let's get started
real quick before we get started just
remember that the tales of the rebellion
event is out and that has its own
free battle pass whereas the year 4
season 3 battle pass which is this blue
one at the top
that is a paid version you can get the
stuff on the bottom which is the premium
and the stuff on the top which is the
free version
of course you could be any tier in the
battle pass let's say your tier 99 and
then you decide to get the premium
version
then it gets all the other stuff here at
the bottom for you
all the way up to 0.99 you don't have to
make your decision now you could do it
right when the season's ending or right
when you hit tier 100
it's totally up to you but starting off
with the first tier we have a new idle
effect
this is that kind of shaman looking hood
we saw
somewhere in last week's kind of
devstream it's kind of cool
i don't know what this means i feel like
there's some sort of like mythology to
this somehow i don't know
why this is here it looks fantastic i
feel like this fits on a few bit of
characters maybe more of the
the stronger looking characters can we
get a picture of that with like
where's shugoki let me just scroll
really quickly all the way to shugoki i
feel like this would fit him
somewhat well i mean that's not bad i i
think more like the thicker characters
you know the warlords the lawbringers
the sugokis would fit pretty well with
that
it's a nice pretty cool looking symbol
you can put on anything you want because
it's an emblem
then you get the battle pass boost to
make sure you get more points faster
if you do buy the premium off the rip
already at tier 2 we start out with
wardens warmonger weapon set i'm not
going to be scrolling too far into the
weapons you can of course check my past
video where we saw those
a lot better in detail the whole shebang
there we're just kind of looking at what
tiers they are
at tier three we end up getting an
outline and then a scavenger crate
at tier four we get some steel 500 steel
to be in
in fact then we get the chimera
rebellion paint pattern not too bad
looks like there's a little bird on the
chest there
get neusha's weapon set at tier six so
already going to the dlc characters
really really interesting the pattern
they're taking with the weapons here
then we get the chimera resolve skin
kind of a more black and red touch to it
not too bad
we then get the 250 salvage at tier viii
the silvon worshipper battle outfit
which is a more yellow
and a more greenish tone so also not too
bad as well
but this is going to be for the woolen
only whereas this one
up here this the chimera resolve is for
the knights only as you can tell by the
logo
for the vikings we're getting the
chimera alliance berserker symbol so not
too bad
tier nine we get that same symbol but
this is now for the boulin
centurion gets his weapon at tier 10 the
xp boost at 11
chimera resolve for the vikings at 11.
we get the chimera rebellion paint
pattern for the knights
and then the vikings get the battle
outfit that we just previously talked
about
i'm assuming this is going to be
swapping and alternating between some of
the factions as you can tell
the worshipper outfit is now for the
knights here at tier 18.
yorman gunder gets his weapon at tier
15.
we get some free steel get some free xp
boost
tier 17 has some salvage and then the
jane june
you know out here with the wool in
getting the paint print the chimera
rebellion 2. it's kind of hard to
actually see on him but you still get
the point
it's just going to be slowly flowing
into all the factions here
tier 19 is aramush's weapon set at 22 is
jj's weapon set
we get the chimera valiance which is a
new color we haven't seen yet here
i don't know if this is just how it
looks on you know my zonu here but it
doesn't seem like it this seems more of
a definite
white being the primary color and of
course if we check that again with
my zan who is there's a bunch of
different colors here
they i believe the yeah it's a light
blue and a purple but i don't really see
the light blue that often
maybe i'm just not looking at it in a
blind but that's not that's not that bad
of a color i definitely appreciate that
color i think that'll be really cool for
a few characters
then we get the symbol for the uh for
the knights
we then get a the color for the roulin
we get the color as well for the woolen
and then
the samurai end up getting the battle
outfits and then we get a new embossing
the sylvan kami which is for the woolen
and then i'm assuming
in the next five or so tiers we'll
probably get it for another faction
then the of course like i said the
vikings this is an embossing for all
characters now
as opposed to this one just being for
the faction specific as we go along
all the factions end up getting this one
this is the aramusha embossing the
silivone
superstition see if i can find a good
character that shows it i mean that's
not bad
i want to get that's better that's way
better right on the chest there not too
bad
sylvan superstition this is pretty cool
i like that 500 steel tiandi getting the
weapon set at 26.
the paint pattern we've seen a bunch the
color we've seen a bunch but now for the
samurai
and of course the color we've seen a
bunch before the samurai as well
your conquer battle outfit new color
sylvan botany more greenish color i
could tell because the the
the color botany there uh it seems like
this is gonna be for the knights
so probably in the next couple tears
we'll be getting the other factions
nice little warlord symbol here for the
chimera alliance three for all the
vikings not bad i really don't see where
this fits in any character it's very
bright very cyberpunk looking
so not really sure how this is going to
fit on some characters but not too bad
the knights end up getting the chimera
valiants color that little white color
we talked about not too bad already
looking at warden here
really solid and my warden's like level
two silvon purifiers
on who's weapon set not too bad looking
this is actually really clean i like the
blade a lot
we get some free salvage and some paid
salvage in here and then a new
paint pattern which is the the chimera
rebellion one let's get a better
character
that's a little bit better not too bad
there's no bird in the middle now looks
like a person with wings and a weapon so
pretty cool
then we have shaolin's weapon set
nobushi's weapon set
xp boost occult the paint pattern we
just talked about before the wool in
the color we just talked about and the
battle outfit we just talked about as
well but now it's for the vikings
next up is that alliance type of symbol
this is going to be for the samurai
shugoky's weapon set is in here as well
the chimera rebellion 3
i don't actually know if we've seen this
one yet i think we have but i want to
refresh my memory a slight bit
it's kind of hard finding a character
that has this this is really
not helping me doesn't look too bad it
looks like there's a couple hands with
some swords though so that's a new paint
pattern for the knights
we then get the botany outfit for the
samurai the
kami embossing for the knights some free
steel and some paid salvage
almost getting to tier 50 hopefully
we're getting some new stuff coming soon
here in a second
hito carrie's weapon set and orochi's
weapon set are within these tiers
the battle outfit that we've seen but
now for the wool in the embossing for
the samurai the paint pattern for the
vikings and some paid
steel moving on halfway through we have
the paint pattern that we've seen but
now for the vikings
shinobi's weapon set at tier 50 exactly
halfway through
the chimera resistance warlord embossing
here
this is that this one is going to be it
seems like for all characters
but do keep in mind this is a whole new
embossing we haven't seen yet where's
peacekeeper
let me bring it up on her it was really
easy to find it on her why can't i find
her
she's at the top that's not too bad
that's very similar to the
the sylvan superstition one that we saw
except this one now has more of a female
head and doesn't have the
kind of antlers it's more like plants
kind of flowing around her so that's
pretty cool
uh we have the symbol we've seen before
we got three days of free champion
status 250 steel
that's free a paid xp boost and that's
it for this section as we move on
we then get the kensei weapon set the
paint pattern we've seen before the
boulin
once again paint pattern but for the
knights then we have a color scheme the
chimera benevolence something we haven't
seen yet
this is going to be for the knights it
seems like let's check in on conquer a
little bit
that's not too bad it's got this orange
and blue kind of feel to it although
it's not exactly orange a little bit
more paler in comparison
but i like that we then get some paid
steel and a new
signature for the knights the silivon
rose
nice we definitely saw that last week
when they were talking about all of the
stuff in the event
and yeah this is totally understandable
like i said we've seen this before but
it's still pretty cool
they basically move their hand and a
rose appears i think it's pretty dope
this then of course comes with the
samurai version which it doesn't
actually seem like it's a rose this time
this is a bonsai tree
super dope i've always liked bonsai
trees definitely makes sense for them
we then get the warlord weapon set and
the valkyrie weapon set
get the hitokiri paint pattern get the
xp boost
the silivone and the sylvan hermit which
is another
embossing here you gotta see it's like
an old man sitting on a little
uh what looks like a leaf or a flower of
some sort so that's gonna be for the
samurai
and yeah like i said the samurai get the
banzai version the knights get the rose
whereas the wulin get bamboo nice
that one's actually way better than the
other three that i just saw
or the other two perfect then raider
gets his weapon set
at 66 the color but now for the vikings
a new symbol the chimera alliance not
too bad once again very bright in colors
a paid scavenger crate i pay some paid
salvage in that embossing
now we get to the last one which is the
vikings they get the brew this time
are they making drinks of course they
are fantastic beautiful entry
excellent sip fantastic delivery
definitely a 10 out of 10 emote there
i would definitely get that if any of
you are viking fans have any viking
characters that looks fantastic
speaking of vikings shaman gets her
weapon set at 72
and highlander gets his at 70. we got
some paid steel
we got some chimera benevolence colors
but this is for the samurai not too bad
actually looks really good unito carry
actually then we get the embossing
for the vikings we're now coming down to
the last quarter of the battle pass we
have berserker's weapon set at 74.
warden's weapon set at 76. wait a minute
was that
wasn't wardens at number one hold on
oh that was warmongers weapon set
oh damn that makes me feel a little dumb
my fault
apparently that was warmonger's weapon
set i thought that was
warden's weapon set interesting anyway
warden's weapon set is now with 76
warmonger's weapon
is at tier one there we go the shaolin
color
a new peacekeeper embossing here it
seems like for the whole crew
off the rip here sylvan druid not too
bad
once again pull it up on peacekeeper
that's not too bad looking
i like that sylvan's hearts which is the
lawbringer weapons set at 79.
we get black priors at 82 an embossing
we've seen before but for the wool in
we now get into the ornaments the
silivone ornament i'm really hoping this
is
a faction based and not just then
everybody gets the same one that would
really suck
because i mean personally this ain't
exactly my favorite ornament i've seen
either way and get to the idol effect
the dusk silvan
this is an orange interesting i
actually kind of like that can we run
that back again
that's cool so this is for
the this enzo this is the dusk sullivan
which ends up being for the vikings
this seems very similar to the one that
we saw in the beginning
is this a different one i have to wonder
shigoki symbol right on the chest there
the sylvan resistance
the peacekeeper weapons at 86. then we
get the ornaments it seems like the
ornaments are
pretty damn close together it's kind of
a shame wasn't exactly a big fan of this
ornament
we then get the dusk sirvan for the
samurai once again
same thing but of course for the samurai
it's paid salvage the knights
once again getting that new dusk solvent
looks really good actually i would
easily pair that with something that's
orange
tier 90 we get the conqueror weapon set
so we're slowly coming down to the last
section of the game here uh tier 93
we get the viking version yeah it
definitely seems like this is either
the exact same emote or the exact sorry
the exact same ornaments are they're
super super close together in terms of
their you know small differences
but either way not really a big fan get
some paid steel get some paid salvage
and a scavenger crate beautiful stuff 94
95 and 96. gladiator weapon set in 94.
the woolen version the dusk servon with
the appropriate ornament
at 96 the xp boost the scavenger crate
another xp boost and now we get to the
last section
silvan metamorphosis let that play
fantastic and this seems to be the exact
same thing of course it's just
every single you know character you know
it's going to be the vikings at 97.
they will in 98 the knights at 99
and then the samurai at 100 i'm gonna
get a better view of this actually
that's pretty good i feel like this
season is really nice
if you end up having a character that
has like all green color schemes i
believe my glide eater has an all green
color scheme so i think this would be
super good for him
in terms of all the stuff i could be
putting here honestly not a bad
execution
i gotta admit though i'm actually really
enjoying the emote that we saw
like i'd say like 20 sections past this
you know on like page 15 or whatever it
was but the banzai tree and the brew
that was way cooler than this execution
but
that's just me i don't really think it
fits with many characters unless they
have like a green
setting to it it just feels awkward
right
and then at tier 100 we get the seven
days and then the snake
outline not too bad this is a pretty
solid battle passes seven days free of
course so in total you will get 10 days
of free champion status
one of the things i wanted to bring up
actually is one of the characters that i
use
for shugoki here is that i have this
little kind of setup here for him where
it's all like green colors
this is more of a blue of course but if
we scroll through the colors you'll
notice that it's all green
but of course they got rid of the colors
so i have to put this back on
what for this character i have some
effects and stuff that are you know the
root and branch effect you know there's
some green to it
whirlwind is close but it's got some
green to it bamboo forest is green
it would just feel weird if this
happened right
there was a pink with a green color
scheme which is why for sugoki
i have that on the pink version see once
again even if we were to do the opposite
and we put the bamboo on this
it just wouldn't look right at least to
me maybe maybe that's just how i am with
my strict
you know characterization and
customization i like the colors to match
and i feel like if a green and a pink
were like that
it just wouldn't make sense so i feel
like if you have any character
that you want to you know add some green
colors to and now with the addition of
the colors being gone and we all get to
use any color we want
you can honestly set aside a third
loadout strictly towards this season in
its style
and just have a bunch of green colors
either way that's going to be me i don't
want to ramble on too much as
we've already talked a bunch about this
battle pass but always guys let me know
what you guys think about this video in
the comments down below let me know what
you guys think of the battle pass is it
worth your 10
or maybe you're gonna see how far you
get buy it or maybe you're never gonna
buy it
let me know the comments down below take
care peace out
and goodbye
[Music]
you